wendy's canada and sports illustrated
are the latest brands to show support
for lisa laflem after her controversial
firing at ctv news yeah so the shock
continues over lisa's sudden departure
from ctv's parent company bell media
after a massively successful 35-year run
an outrage quickly followed when it was
reported that company exec michael
melling questioned lisa's choice to stop
dyeing her hair during the pandemic oh
yes this has since raised several
questions over sexism and ageism in the
workplace and rightfully so with many
people and brands showing support for
lisa's gray hair dove canada was the
first brand to seemingly call out bell
media in a new campaign urging women to
keep the gray and embrace getting older
and now wendy's has followed suit by
changing the mascot's iconic red
pigtails for a shade of grey they
directly showed support for lisa in
their tweet writing alongside because a
star is a star regardless of hair color
hashtag lisa flam
new profile pic and sports illustrated
also showed their support changing the
color of mae musk's swimsuit cover
writing on twitter
we are going gray with dove in support
of women aging confidently on their own
terms we were so proud to feature mae
musk on our may 22 swimsuit cover living
proof that beauty only gets better with
age hashtag keep the gray keep the gray
indeed now this is where things get
interesting since the latest campaigns
have been capitalizing on the backlash
marketing experts are warning that
brands could face blowback from
customers and employees retail analyst
bruce winder says this is a high risk
move explaining every brand has
skeletons in the closet and this does
very much open them up to scrutiny so
you better make sure your house is in
order before you start throwing the
shade out there
[Music]
i understand i get it and sure whenever
anything is all over the news the way
that the the firing of lisa leflem has
continued to be in the news i have not
seen this slow down i'm glad it is sure
there have been times in the past where
we have seen companies kind of uh
not take advantage but capitalize on
that oh do you mean like kendall
and the pepsi commercial
maybe maybe that is one example that is
the example that comes to mind and that
was really that was that was distasteful
so but i don't see it with this
situation because
what this has turned into a whole other
conversation it was once uh you know at
the beginning about lisa laflamme and it
was the outrage and here's a woman who's
been in this career for 35 years you
know people who had had this position in
the past they were in their 70s before
they got to retire at their own uh
choosing hair color clear
has never been an issue for men why is
it an issue now but then it has spawned
this huge conversation around the world
about ageism yeah about sexism uh you
know this is something women are dealing
with
constantly on a daily basis and as we've
said not just people who are in front of
the television
people in their jobs in general so i
love that these companies are doing it
to me
they're not you know just kind of
writing the coattails of this of what's
happened they're they're
showcasing that they are supporting
what has happened and and and the
injustice of what women go through i
understand that but i also understand
how sometimes it can seem a bit
opportunistic so in my own mind i am
curious uh has wendy's hold their
advertisements from bell media
yeah that's a good question i don't know
um so i understand both aspects i love
the fact that this it wasn't just a news
story that you know broke and kind of
disappeared disappeared because i feel
like that's what happens a lot we're
always moving on to the very next true
we're upset and then and then something
else happens outraged and then we're
over it but no we can't get over this
she
is an icon of canadian broadcasting and
for her to be fired this way is
disgusting it is and that's why i
actually love that these other companies
that i did not see coming i had no idea
dove would do this wendy's like i just
love because they're continuing this
very important conversation uh vanessa's
saying i think this is awesome that
these brands are capitalizing on lisa
leflam's controversy embrace the gray uh
visario saying hey the firing elisa flam
should be reversed or she should sue ctv
hire a lawyer stillwell studios is
saying hey the hulk was originally gray
when he first debuted maybe marvel
should do a gray hulk promotion too i
like these various brands going grey
campaign
i i it's hard for me i agree i love that
we're continuing it i love that they're
showing their support but
there is the other aspect that you know
are we actually
doing what we're saying we're doing are
we still airing ads on these
networks yeah let's get a little deeper
here i don't know
good question good question i like it